[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the White House has
released their offer for an immigration
deal their proposal gives so-called
dreamers essentially everything they
said they wanted legalization and a path
to citizenship so millions of people who
broke our laws to get here would receive
amnesty very few of the president's
supporters voted for that when they put
him in office last year and some of them
are upset about it and the left what's
their reaction like well having gotten
pretty much exactly what they demanded
they're enraged not only is Trump's
amnesty offer not enough they say it is
evidence of a racist plot according to
the ACLU quote the only community that
benefits from the supposed generosity
are white supremacists United We Dream
that's one of the largest Pro amnesty
groups call the proposal quote a white
supremacist ransom note the columnist
Shaun King said the plan proved that
quote the current operating philosophy
of Trump and the White House is white
supremacy immigration activist Eddie
Vail called the proposal a legislative
burning cross and the senior Democrat in
the House of Representatives said this
last night the president put forth a
plan that plan is a campaign to make
America white again they are changing
the character of our country by what
they are putting forth they bring a tear
to the eye of the Statue of Liberty and
they were in fear to the hearts of
people are here playing by the rules we
can go on and on and on it's everywhere
today you see the point they're telling
you this plan is something the Klan
could have produced and probably did
okay but is it we took those charges
seriously because we felt we should and
we decided to take a close look at what
the White House is actually proposed we
found that the plan may be many things
not all of them good by the way but it
definitely isn't a form of white
nationalism not unless that term now has
the opposite meaning let's go through it
the White House proposal would legalize
about two million people who currently
have no right to be here that's a lot of
people for perspective 13 US states have
populations smaller than that
Barack Obama never enacted an amnesty
that big how many of those beneficiaries
are white now keep in mind that would be
the central question in any plan crafted
by white supremacists obviously well
let's see almost none of them hmm two
million more non-white people in this
country that's more than the total
population of Delaware or Nebraska
doesn't sound much like a legislative
burning cross but there's more the
proposal would also continue the current
system of chain migration until the
backlog of applicants has been exhausted
that would take years and years what
countries will be the top beneficiaries
of this new arrangement under the Trump
plan well if you guessed Finland Norway
the Swedish national sauna team no guess
again no European countries are on that
list not one instead the plan would
admit nearly a million more immigrants
from Mexico and hundreds of thousands
more from India also Vietnam Bangladesh
the Dominican Republic and China the
Philippines - the plan would even bring
in more than 50,000 additional
immigrants from Haiti the country that
president supposedly hates surprised you
shouldn't be no matter what the race
baiters on television are telling you no
majority white countries send large
numbers of immigrants to the United
States and haven't in 50 years that
would not change under this proposal a
white nationalist plot in the history of
dumb and dishonest Washington talking
points that may be the dumbest and most
dishonest of all and it's poisonous - it
makes people hate each other and it
further divides this country and we do
not need more of that the people who are
repeating it ought to be ashamed of
themselves so of course they're not they
have to know they're lying then again
maybe they don't know they're lying
maybe they've actually convinced
themselves their rhetoric is true it's
possible the Democratic Party really has
gone that insane their new position as
that is that it's immoral to restrict
any kind of vinum immigration from any
country in any amount for any reason
ever even enforcing our own existing
laws the ones that they voted for and
passed in Congress is now tantamount to
a hate crime Nancy Pelosi has been
making that case for months now the
public doesn't agree with any of this so
by definition
Democrats are extremists on the subject
they don't care
this is their new electoral strategy
these are their new voters whatever it
takes